two months after returning emmanuel
macron to the presidency french voters
are electing a parliament high in their
minds the climate crisis and cost of
living
i think the essential question of our
era is climate and the planet and that
important things must be done
immediately
measures are needed in terms of the
current situation to deal with our
purchasing power and competitiveness the
question is how do we despise the
current situation keep moving forward
macron's centrist ensemble coalition
faces a strong challenge from a far-left
alliance built by jean-luc melenchon if
the leftists greens and communists do
well they could block much of macron's
agenda making france as one analyst
pointed out ungovernable the country is
ungovernable
if you have a
weak majority that does not mean that
you can run the country and you very
well have in the next months a huge
uprise of
people saying well we're not happy with
the president's decisions we do not
consider that the mps can solve a
problem so where can we solve it and you
can have this
street
let's say street democracy france has a
strong tradition of street protest like
the yellow vests that made macron's
first term so uncomfortable with their
demands for economic justice and
political reform this election could
provoke similar scenes the leftist
coalition has its own ideas about how to
deal with france's cost of living crisis
soaring inflation let alone eu policy
and the war in ukraine it is entirely
possible that in the new parliament the
centrists could find their way blocked
at every turn
five years ago emmanuel macron completed
a clean sweep of power with his
centrists winning the parliament as well
his second term as president could turn
out rather differently
these are two political forces with very
different visions of the future the
leftists and the centrists the leftists
want to raise taxes on the wealthy raise
the minimum wage and lower the
retirement age the centrists want to
raise the retirement age lower taxes and
reform the welfare system 289 the number
of seats required by either side to win
an outright majority but even if there
is no outright majority for the leftists
a strong minority can still wield
significant power in this system so that
the new national assembly when it's
formed looks set to be able potentially
to frustrate and undermine president
macron's second term agenda
jonah thank you for that jonah hall
alive there in paris
not only i spoke to anne elizabeth mute
who's a political commentator based in
the french capital she says the second
round of voting may introduce a third
party to the race
i think jean-luc milo shows alliance
because it's not his party alone but i
think his alliance has got momentum and
they might uh get close to majority it
seems almost impossible that in a
country which has voted in the
presidential elections for two-thirds on
right-wing candidates that the left
could get that close but that's what it
means when you get we all manage to
organize uh an alliance of all the
parties even if they disagree among
themselves uh
he i would this is the first round uh
what's going to be really interesting is
the second round in a week's time uh
when you've got the
um the candidates that remain above 12
and a half percent of the registered
voters they can stay in so it's not just
going to be one candidate against
another one like in the presidential
election it is going to be actually
possibly what we in france call
triangular elections which means that
you have say a macronista you have a
right-winger what's left of them and
then you've got you've got the new pest
the miloshaw thing and that is one
instance in which if they can't get to
terms one with the other um in which
mineral short milo mps could get in but
that's only in the in the second round
next week and emmanuel macron's faith in
himself is that at the end of the day
people will be scared of jean-luc minor
it may or may not work